Hello, and welcome
back "Route 85"
and part 4 on our little series
on opening a link in Chrome
on iOS.
Now if you've been following
along up until this point,
we've basically
finished our main goal
of opening up a link in Chrome,
adding a Back button that
reopens our app, and
using our open source
library to help you do it
all quickly and easily.
So you can think
of today's episode
as a little bit of extra credit.
See, as long as we're exploring
the idea of URL schemes
and callback URLs,
let's take a closer look
at this x-success callback
URL that we are defining.
Right now it's just sent
to my app's custom scheme
and that's it.
But we could actually
embed any information
we want in this URL.
Let's say, for
instance, we wanted
to tell the user how happy
we are that they clicked
on that Back button when
they came back to our app.
Well, we could modify our
callback URL to be something
like comgooglemyexamp
le://welcomeback/.
If we URL encode
this thing, and make
it part of our
x-callback URL, this
will get passed along
to Chrome as the URL
to open when the user clicks
the Back button to go back
to our app.
So when Chrome intends
to open this URL,
iOS will open up
our application--
because we've claimed ownership
to the comgooglemyexample
custom URL scheme-- and then we
will pass this full URL along
to our application's
app delegate.
But then how do we
read in this URL
that gets sent back to our app?
By implementing the application
openURL sourceApplication
annotation method,
in our app delegate.
This takes in the full
URL that opened up
our app in the first place,
along with a few other bits
of information.
So maybe this is better
demonstrated in code,
so let's give it a
try in our sample app.
So here we are back in my
fancy opening Chrome example
application.
And I'm going to
do two things here.
The first thing I'm going to do
is change my callback URL from
just this
comgoogleopeninchromeexample:
to comgoogleopenexa
mple://welcomebackfrombutton/.
And then the next
thing I'm going to do,
is jump into my
AppDelegate.m file.
And let's say up
here at the top,
I'm going to add this
application open URL source
application annotation method
that I alluded to earlier.
So this is application--
here it is.
Open URL, source
application, annotation.
And I guess maybe the
first thing I will do here
is, let's just log the
URL that we get back.
So nslog.
I have received the URL.
And then we'll pass
in URL absolutestring.
But spoiler alert,
it's just going
to be the callback
URL that we specified
in our viewcontroller.m file.
And we can return
Yes for now, just
to say yes, I can handle this
URL-- even though I actually
don't know what it is yet.
And so now, when we run
this-- so click on the button,
go into Chrome, jump back.
Let's stop this.
And we could see that
in the logs, yes,
the URL we've
received is, in fact,
this comgoogleopening
chromeexample://
welcomebackfrombutton.
Man, I need shorter URLs.
But now we can analyze that.
So I'm going to add a little
if URL host is equal to string,
and this is
welcomebackfrombutton--
so if this is the case, then we
know that the user has gotten
into our application from
clicking on that Back
button in Chrome,
and not from, say,
another x-callback URL we
were to create in the future.
And so then, why don't we add
a little alert box or something
to welcome the user back.
Something like this-- UIAlert
view alloc initWithTitle@
Welcome Back!
Message-- We Missed You!
Our delegate here can be nil.
Cancel button can be Awww.
And other button titles,
there aren't any.
And Show.
There we go.
Oops.
Yes, I need the little at sign.
There we go.
And then, I am
returning yes here,
at the end of this
method, to signal
that, yes, we have
properly handled the URL.
I'm not actually sure what
effect this has on the app,
since I can return no here, and
I still get to open the URL.
My suspicion is that you want
to return the correct value here
in case you have a
subclass app delegate.
And your subclass
delegate, you need
to know whether or not
you have a URL that
hasn't been handled
yet by your Super.
But that's just a guess.
I don't really know for sure.
Anyway, let's run this.
So I tap my button,
it goes into Chrome.
Tap the Back button.
Ah, and look at that.
It's the "Welcome
Back!" dialogue.
Aw, I feel so loved.
For a more realistic
example, we could
imagine that we had an app that
contained a bunch of news story
headlines, and a user could
click on one of those headlines
to read the full
story in Chrome.
So we could pass along,
within our URL arguments,
the internal ID of whatever
story or news post contained
this external link
in the first place.
Then when the user
returns to our app,
we can use this information
to, for example,
make sure the user
continues browsing
from where they left off.
Or we could prop them with
some follow-up options.
Or we can mark
this story as read.
You kind of get the idea.
Anyway, hopefully this
tutorial gives you
a better understanding
of what URL schemes are,
how to use them to open up
a web page in the user's
favorite browser--
whatever that might be--
and how to take advantage
of that nice little Back
button in Chrome to send
the user back to your app.
So, thanks so much for watching.
Hey, this was my first set
of screen caps in a while.
What'd you think?
Was this too fast, too slow?
Is there something else
you want me to cover?
Are you like, let's do
all swift all the time?
Let me know down
here in the comments,
and I will be sure to read them.
Thanks again, and
I'll talk to you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]